Cascade Platinum.
>> 1,870,000 TESTS TO DATE.
NOW WE ARE PERFORMING THEM AT A
LEVEL THAT NOBODY HAS EVER SEEN
BEFORE.
CVS TESTING SITES IN GEORGIA AND
RHODE ISLAND WILL BE USING
ABBOTT LABS.
RAPID 5 MINUTE TEST.
THAT MEANS A LOT OF VERY
FASTEST.
NO NATION IN THE WORLD DEVELOPED
A MORE DIVERSE AND ROBUST
TESTING CAPACITY THAN THE UNITED
STATES.
BRIAN: PRESIDENT TRUMP
HIGHLIGHTING THE EXPANSION OF
THE CORONAVIRUS TESTING
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
STEVE: HERE WITH MORE IS
ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AND A MEIVELT
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS TASK
FORCE 4 STAR ADMIRABLE BRET
GIROIR.
ADMIRAL, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
STEVE: IT’S GREAT TO HAVE YOU
BECAUSE YOU ARE GIVING AMERICA
UPDATES ON THE VERY LATEST.
IT’S INTERESTING.
WE WERE LISTENING TO DR. BIRX
AND THE PRESIDENT LAST NIGHT
TALK FROM THE PODIUM IN THE
BRIEFING ROOM ABOUT THESE ABBOTT
MACHINES.
SHE HAD AN APPEAL THAT IF YOU
HAVE GOT ONE LET’S TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW YOUR AREA CAN USE IT.
COULD YOU JUST EXPLAIN WHAT SHE
IS TALKING ABOUT AND WHAT THESE
ABBOTT MACHINES CAN DO?
ABBOTT MAKES A VARIETY OF
MACHINES.
THE TEST YOU ALLUDED TO WHAT
DR. BIRX WAS REFERRING TO THREW
PUT MACHINE THAT ABBOTT MAKES
THAT WE KNOW A LOT OF HOSPITALS
HAVE AND WE ARE ABLE TO TRACK
EXACTLY HOW MANY TESTS THEY ARE
DOING AND MAXIMIZE THE CAPACITY
OF THE COUNTRY.
WE WANT THOSE MACHINES TO BE IN
FULL YOURS.
GOING TO AN INDIVIDUAL,
INDIVIDUAL KIND OF HOSPITAL WORK
RIGHT NOW TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY POSSIBLE TEST THAT CAN BE
RUN WILL BE RUN.
AINSLEY: DR. BIRX WAS TALKING
ABOUT ANTIBODY TEST AND I HADN’T
EVEN THOUGHT OF THIS UNTIL SHE
MENTIONED IT.
SHE SAID THERE ARE SOME
COMPANIES THROUGHOUT TRYING TO
SELL ANTIBODY TESTS ONLINE.
SHE WARNS PEOPLE -- WELL, HERE
IS HER WARNING.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> IF YOU SEE THEM ON THE
INTERNET, DO NOT BUY THEM SOME
OF THE TESTS THAT MAY BE
AVAILABLE ON THE INTERNET MAY
HAVE VERY LOW SENSITIVITY AND
SPECIFICITY AND GIVE YOU A FALSE
REASSURANCE THAT YOU EITHER GIVE
YOU A FALSE POSITIVE OR A FALSE
NEGATIVE IMPLYING YOU MAY BE
PROTECTED.
AINSLEY: WHAT’S YOUR MESSAGE FOR
THE FOLKS THAT ARE WATCHING.
THERE HASN’T BEEN ONE THAT’S
BEEN APPROVED RIGHT OR IT’S NOT
AVAILABLE?
>> SO, I WANT TO DISTINGUISH FOR
ALL YOUR VIEWERS, UP UNTIL NOW
ALL THE TESTS WE HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING ABOUT DIAGNOSE DO YOU
HAVE THE VIRUS IN YOUR NOSE?
ARE YOU ACTIVELY SHEDDING, ARE
YOU INFECTED.
THE ANTIBODY TEST WOULD BE ABLE
TO TELL YOU HAVE YOU BEEN
INFECTED IN THE PAST.
SO, IT DETECTS AN IMMUNE
RESPONSE TO THE VICE MEANING YOU
ARE NOT LIKELY EVER GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET IT AGAIN OR AT LEAST
IN THE SHORT-TERM OF MANY YEARS
THAT’S THE TEST RIGHT NOW THAT
ARE COMING ONTO THE MARKET.
MOST OF THEM, ALMOST ALL OF THEM
HAVE NOT BEEN THROUGH FDA
AUTHORIZATION.
AND WE ARE VERY CONCERNED THAT
MANY OF THE TESTS ARE REALLY
JUST NOT ACCURATE SO IN THE
GOVERNMENT NIC, NIH ARE TRYING
TO VALIDATE ALL OF THE TESTS
THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT WE KNOW
ABOUT TO MAKE SURE THEY REALLY
PERFORM.
WE HAVE HEARD INTERNATIONAL
STORIES OF GOVERNMENTS AND YOU
MIGHT HAVE SEEN IT A COUPLE DAYS
AGO THE UNITED KINGDOM BOUGHT
ALMOST 20 MILLION TESTS AND THEY
JUST DON’T WORK AT ALL.
THEY DON’T PERFORM WELL.
THERE IS NO NEED TO HAVE THIS
TEST RIGHT NOW WE ARE DEVELOPING
THE METHODS.
WE HAVE THE METHODS AND
VALIDATING WHICH TESTS ARE GOOD
AND AS SOON AS WE DO THAT YOU
WILL BE HEARING FROM US VERY
SHORTLY.
PROBABLY IN THE NEXT WEEK TO
GIVE THE PUBLIC ASSURANCE OF
WHICH ONES REALLY WORK AND
DON’T.
THERE WILL BE A REALLY NATIONAL
TESTING PLAN AROUND THESE
ANTIBODY TESTS AS WELL.
BRIAN: ADMIRAL, A COUPLE DAYS
AGO FAMOUSLY YOU TOOK A QUESTION
FROM THE PODIUM AND THEY SAID
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL DID A
REPORT AND IT TURNS OUT A SURVEY
OF 300 PLUS HOSPITALS SHOW THE
PREVAILING THOUGHT WAS THERE
WASN’T ENOUGH GLOVES, THERE
WASN’T ENOUGH SHIELDS.
THERE WASN’T ENOUGH MASKS.
YOU SAID WELL, IF THAT -- THAT’S
NOT THE CASE BUT IF IT WAS TRUE
I WISH THAT PERSON WOULD HAVE
TOLD ME RATHER THAN RUN TO THE
PRESS.
HOW MANY HOSPITALS DO YOU THINK
ARE SHORT OF ANY OF THESE
THINGS?
>> WELL, IT’S -- WE GET SOURCED
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE HAVE REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS
FROM FEMA.
WE HAVE HHS REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS.
WE TALK TO MOST OF THE MAJOR
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS DIRECTLY.
PARTICULARLY IN THE HOT SPOT
AREAS.
AND UP UNTIL NOW, PARTICULARLY
WITH GOWNS, GLOVES, N-95 MASKS,
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FILL ALL
THE NEEDS THAT WE HAVE BEEN TOLD
ABOUT.
AT FIRST WE STARTED AT REGIONAL
LEVEL AND NAU GOING DOWN TO
INDIVIDUAL HOSPITALS.
I KNOW THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN
IN A COMMUNITY.
I’M AN INTENSIVE CARE DOCTOR.
IF YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT NOT
HAVING THE RIGHT MASKS OR, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF THE MASKS ARE
SITTING IN A WAREHOUSE DOWN THE
STREET.
THEY HAVE BEEN DELIVERED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT HAVEN’T
GOTTEN TO YOUR HOSPITAL, THAT IS
A CONCERN.
THAT’S WHY WE HAVE EVEN MOVED TO
THE NEXT STEP HERE AT FEMA AND
HHS BY SUPPLYING HOSPITALS
SPECIFICALLY, GOING DOOR TO
DOOR.
IF THAT HOSPITAL HAS A NEED AND
THEY ARE NOT GETTING MET THAT WE
REALLY DO THAT SO THAT’S REALLY
THE POSTURE WE ARE IN RIGHT NOW.
YES.
STEVE: OKAY.
BUT, ULTIMATELY, ADMIRAL, THAT’S
AFTER SOMEBODY BECOMES INFECTED
AND THEY NEED HOSPITALIZATION
AND THAT’S WHEN THEY WIND UP ON
ONE OF THE BEDS OR ONE OF THE
ICU BEDS AS WELL.
>> CORRECT, CORRECT.
STEVE: RIGHT NOW WHAT’S VERY
ENCOURAGING IS THE FACT THAT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING, THAT FOR THE MOST
PART THE ENTIRE COUNTRY IS
DOING, AND WE SHOULD POINT OUT
THAT THE CDC DIRECTOR SAID A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO SAID
YESTERDAY, THAT APPARENTLY, YOU
KNOW, THOSE SUPER DIRE
PREDICTIONS THAT MAYBE A QUARTER
OF A MILLION AMERICANS COULD
DIE, THAT WAS AWFUL, BUT, AT THE
SAME TIME, NOW THEY ARE SAYING
IT PROBABLY WON’T BE THAT BAD
BECAUSE THOSE ESTIMATES WERE
BASED ON ONLY HALF THE COUNTRY
DOING SOCIAL DISTANCING.
RIGHT NOW, IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYBODY IS IN THIS.
FOR THE FOLKS WATCHING RIGHT
NOW, THEY HAVE GOT TO KNOW THAT
WHAT THEY ARE DOING, STAYING
AWAY FROM PEOPLE, IS ACTUALLY
WORKING AND IT WILL SAVE LIVES.
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND ALL THE
PRECAUTIONS THAT WE HAVE SAID
EVERY DAY THAT THE PRESIDENT AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT SAID AND
AMBASSADOR BIRX, THEY WORK.
THEY REALLY DO WORK.
AND THAT’S HOW YOU STOP THIS
VIRUS RIGHT NOW.
UNTIL WE HAVE VACCINES AND
MEDICATIONS AND ALL THE OTHER
THINGS, SOCIAL DISTANCING, I
PREFER TO CALL IT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING.
I WANT YOU TO STILL BE SOCIAL
WITH YOUR FRIENDS OVER FACEBOOK.
BUT PHYSICAL DISTANCING IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
REMEMBER THE PROJECTIONS.
I HAVE SEEN PEOPLE TWIST THAT
LIKE THIS WAS NOT GOING TO BE
THAT BAD AFTER ALL AND WE DIDN’T
NEED TO DO IT.
THAT’S A COMPLETE
MISINTERPRETATION.
THE ESTIMATE OF DEATHS GOING
DOWN IS THE RESULT OF THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE LISTENED TO THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT AND
TASKS FORCE.
IF WE DID NOTHING THE DEATHS
COULD HAVE BEEN 2 MILLION,
3 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
USING MODERATE IMPACT SOCIAL
DISTANCING IT COULD HAVE BEEN A
COUPLE HUNDRED THOUSANDS.
NOW WE KNOW THAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC IS DOING A FANTASTIC JOB
IN DOING THAT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING.
EARLY ESTIMATES ARE PROBABLY
UNDER 100,000.
THAT’S STILL A HORRIBLE AMOUNT
OF DEATHS BUT MUCH LESS THAN IT
COULD HAVE BEEN.
I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
POINT, THERE IS A LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL, BUT DON’T
KEEP YOUR FOOT -- DON’T TAKE
YOUR FOOT OFF THE GAS.
BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED TO
CONTINUE THESE EFFORTS BECAUSE
WE COULD SEE ANOTHER PEAK, A
SECOND PEAK, A THIRD PEAK IF
PEOPLE DON’T DO THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING OR THEY THINK IT’S
ALL OVER.
IT’S NOT OVER YET.
LISTEN TO WHAT WE EXPLAIN ON THE
PODIUM AND ALSO YOUR STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
AINSLEY: GOOD ADVICE, ADMIRAL.